hello and welcome to video playing
arrows Grand Master Eric Hanson what
does he do with black actually now the
green felt okay everybody nowadays goes
castles rook c1b should be six and he
also does that Jim this is a lie way I
definitely should study a little bit
more because um it seems to be tricky
for white yeah i usually don't get
anything and in some games i also have
problems with with white and that really
shouldn't happen I mean being allowing
equality as one thing but being in
trouble really shouldn't happen I mean
probably taking f6 Bishop of 75 is
something is this something that I had
on the board in in earlier games not
against him but against other other
players here in the ICC five-minute poor
even at five as feasible now but taking
taking looks good and then notice f6
business or this one opening opening it
up
Kieran looks slightly unnatural I can
take everything Queen 85 m and this i
don't i don't play this this line
particularly well there should be six as
a problem line that i have to definitely
i have to study to avoid opening issues
I mean okay I'm like describing this
like I'm lost here or anything I don't
think I am but I'm still not very happy
with the opening result 95 of course o
night c5 stupid stupid stupid yep okay
okay okay
still okay since see five books e5
should be okay and maybe I can still put
up some fight it's not so easy to make
something of the sea porn
now let's prevent any ideas to return it
in at least I'm kind of okay clockwise
this is always held for me and it causes
quite a quick player no 95 next that
should be kind of okay Kim seems like
i'm getting the porn bag on and all he
has to play a night xe5
ideas will be settlement do something
against e7 pawn
you may fire head on the clock check
just push up g for you I can take now
Bishop you five Jim
pretty see much happening anyway to
almost check
oh wait not rookie a place that wouldn't
be a particularly successful idea
he wants 20 Bishop everyone play for
some some kind of chick medium is that
dangerous yeah I kind of I want to go to
f4 against this I guess that's not
really great them it's not really great
this is ok again taking I can still do
I'm a bishop might might have some some
trouble moving actually it doesn't have
a great squares but I can go look h8 so
check so what are you doing time working
toward God forgave to I made him stick
him there should be five my is doing a
good job here still putting China
pressure on me
check check check check game draw Oh 182
moves we okay yeah and this time somehow
screwed to draw out of this yeah it did
a very good job still putting some kind
of problems i think this shouldn't
happen actually from this kind of
position but you know is a good play out
can you do yeah it i had a bad opening
here a better opening result yep now and
here well i saw it right after I played
Quincy one I probably have to play Queen
d2 even though I still don't like my
position I mean black has this f6 Bishop
back a5 idea and I definitely have to
improve reform yeah here i'm just
sitting there with the pawn down it is
an interesting engine suggestion
probably is just a strong move pawn
takes rook c8 c6 I'm not keeping this
and turning takes i'm also not keeping
oh yeah yeah that that is very bad and
here I'm kind of hanging on at least a
little bit of course black still better
but it's okay oh yeah I have very very
decent drawing chances check yeah it's
still suggest probably a draw it I mean
but it's got to know I shaklee really
managed to put many vehicles many
problems even though we had no time at
all check check okay until ultimately
court that check ok c 5 pretty move
check pre move stuff is that actually a
draw
not sure about it
if I got the King here and the bishop to
d4 it's a draw not sure if i get there i
mean ok i had no time whatsoever so i
just played played played they're
probably here it's losing check yeah but
ok it's sir here we've got you were just
pre moving like crazy and he is super
quick so and I mean I was happy not to
lose this the stuff on time ok well
thanks for watching